[Music]
so Victoria's Secret
what's the secret I like it I like it
I like to touch all the panties so that
I know that all these future vaginas to
have two hands on them Victoria's Secret
underwear is not as horny ish it's
pretty honey that's horny pink in the
pink stuff like that Fred nargis
Frederick styling the stuff that she
wears
agent proplica dears that's good oh you
got a brand yeah another one is so like
you Andy
another one is what nothing you don't
pick up do you ever figure the pains in
the store like I do and I go I think the
panties and go I think I pick them up
and I go and then you walk up the store
and the thing buzzes and you're like
okay so the New York cut it out you make
me nervous
okay the New York Times released this
shocking expose my knees out of a dryer
smells amazing not before the drop I
mean Sony men like that I know I don't
know why it's my people is the article
we found Victoria's Secret what yes yes
is this yes it has to be right it is I
hope they did yeah the only time she got
herpes eventually it was titled angels
in hell oh no missed opportunity no and
it says the culture of misogyny inside
Victoria's Secret big shocker right oh
sorry I thought of all chicks that work
there no I thought it was all hot girls
in lingerie and then when you go to the
factory there's a bunch of girls in
bikinis and lingerie and then when you
go to their modeling show it's all those
chicks getting will paid and they're
[ __ ] running
welcome to line 30 million a year when
you go to the factories oompa-loompas in
lingerie oh man no pretty hot lady one
right lacy was here okay Wow it turns
out the guy who owns El Brant or like
the meme guy it's his name is Leslie and
then this other guy that's the problem
yeah an innocent guy named Leslie no
straight guy named Leslie so this other
dude his name is Edie and he's a top
executive for the branding he ran most
of the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
which they canceled last year and he
actually stepped down from his position
in August so this dude named Edie is the
one that were mainly talking about here
he's 71 years old he has a lot of
alleged inappropriate behavior girls for
50 years Sammy and so-and-so
dirty old man yeah pretty much Sookie
his behaviors included asking models to
sit on his lap yeah to kiss them roping
them verbally harassing them and using
his power over their careers this is
Victoria's Secret it's not hustler
magazine your and the wrong company as
it's not Playboy yeah and yeah but then
Wayne complaints were sent to Leslie he
just shrugged them off like I am nothing
was done
so Leslie Leslie you enabling son of a
[ __ ] exactly sounds like some Harvey
Weinstein [ __ ] a lingerie company yeah
you know its sorrows me because of that
yeah so this is Edie and then oh so
Bella Hadid is in this photo because
they're talking about this one instance
where he pretty much said something
along the lines of like oh yeah skip the
underwear let her walk down with those
perfect tits does that perfect I was
picturing Victoria's Secret to be his
own grandma and she had these black and
white photos of her in lingerie to it
that was my heart
like that you know she's like that was
mushy I [ __ ] design my own patties
because back then panties look like [ __ ]
and so she designed her own panties and
she became a CEO I think that's my
[ __ ] imagination of Victoria's Secret
this dude I don't know there was [ __ ]
man running that [ __ ] so this is Leslie
here that's Leslie in that dead are they
gay are they twins no because I heard
the original the original person that
started it they were going bankrupt or
something and they finally built it up
to like I don't like a million or
something and then once they sold it the
new owners came in and made it take off
and he's like oh [ __ ] I shouldn't have
sold it so in 1982
Leslie bought Victoria's Secret for 1
million yeah 1 million and then now it's
like I don't know if I nine figures is
the other cat he hired difficut yeah so
so Edie has been on board since the 80s
yeah he's yeah they're like best friends
pretty much they're not they're not gay
best friends well no if the other guys
getting trying to get out uh
yeah he's definitely buying it oh ok but
if he's gay and he had these chicks
semanas laughs I think we're all good
yeah the girls wouldn't mind good then
it's like girl town and like can you
feel my boob because I think I might
have breast cancer and he's like no
problems no problem okay so they're also
so in this whole New York Times expose
thing they're talking about instances
where Edie would put his hand over a
models crotch or he would sit down in a
couch in views was the crotch popping
out so he didn't want the camera to see
it he's trying to cover it he's trying
to cop a feel pretty authorize been a
gentleman no he's trying to cop a feel
that so and in other instances he would
be sitting in a couch watching these
models get a dress for the show or
whatever and like just being a [ __ ]
creep about it and then also they were
mentioning in here that last year
Leslie's ties to Jeffrey Epstein
he became public oh say it ain't so TIFF
so Epstein
he used to manage Leslie's fortune and
he used to lure young women by posing as
a recruiter for Victoria's Secret models
oh absolutely yes
Epstein did that and so they he would
pretend that he was a recruiter so he'd
be like oh yeah you know I can get you
into Victoria's Secret that's how it
starts yeah I can make you a spy and you
would sex traffic them yes yes allegedly
hello yeah you know he's never been
tried okay right right because he died
before he can even get there when he
killed himself he did okay that's not
what the doctor said yeah I heard about
that but then I heard from a lot of the
media that he's a quack oh yeah yeah I
just count all that huh so anyway this
whole thing here is just shining a light
into the toxic it's a times up movement
Time's Up [ __ ] you've been
groping girls too long pretty much so
now we're thinking I do they going to
kick out their own owner or CEO CEO well
Leslie is exploring plans to retire and
to sell the lingerie company damn -
Victoria - Victoria where's the big
words Victoria's heirs they should be
the rightful owner right yeah who is
miss secret right so well they're
talking about elbrun Elle brands which
is the company exactly the conglomerate
that owns Victoria see y'all stop let me
tell you a secret I recently bought a
[ __ ] ton of PJs really yeah cuz they had
a really good sell they have great great
salesmen I think that's how they're
staying afloat they have really good and
the pink brand saved them thing I I was
just gonna say I was shooting a music
video and I had like ladies in it and I
you know we wanted them all to match and
there was a five panties for $30 at pink
you know say wow five pennies do this
five it looks good and it's affordable
that's cheap if your toy secret did not
used to be that way I remember when I
was a teen chicks in [ __ ] middle
school and and like between-meal in high
school Victoria was [ __ ] spensive bro
oh and remember Victoria Secret in in
high school junior high every girl had
loves
and it was like it was the best I will
love smell the scent it's good smell
ocean oh man that was my sheep yeah I'm
with you I am like no I had four
girlfriends that smelled exactly this
all that spilling all the guys were just
wearing active body spray yeah yeah on
your best day those guys to me I was
like Jesus put something on or take
something off yeah the dudes that loaded
up on ax back then definitely went like
the whole [ __ ] bottle commercial tell
you how to do it there's either guys in
armpit our guys a [ __ ] clue on store
I was never in between sex yeah that's
true where did you fall I smell good
always but I use deodorant I don't
[ __ ] [ __ ] with this what's your
choice Old Spice always really yeah I'm
a degree guy but not smelled like
cigarettes or weed and Bo probably
Japanese men don't stink what no they
don't stink they do stink do they yes do
you say if it rains Old Spice has some
[ __ ] to where you can get a deodorant
that doesn't sweat too much and nothing
anti green smells so good he's debating
right now yes back to victory
oh yeah I guess agree [ __ ] brandy oh
well yes so actually this came out
people were like OMG this is what the
malls have to go through which to me I'm
like really is this afraid Oh another
one that they pointed out was one of
their photographers so this dude would
kind of like so he'd be taking photos
for the petals he'd be taking photos for
the catalogs and then these models
because so then he'd be doing other work
outside of Victoria Secret and so he
could taking photos of these girls and
then he'd be like oh you know after I'm
gonna do like a nude photo shoot if you
want to join I mean no pressure you're
not getting paid for this something for
I could jack off later with me right
like you know if you want to join so
then these girls would be like they
would think like oh you know I'm down
I'll do it I won't get paid and then
maybe this could be my entry to Victoria
Secret cuz this guy would kind of like
insinuate that he could get the men but
then he's David he's asking for photos
that are like this ok can you can you do
like a dis one but if it's a situation
where he's saying hey no pressure come
if you want then is the exact word the
picture painting was like he's like hey
man it's on you well ok this is the part
that it doesn't sit well with the
writers of this article so they're
saying that so back in 2014 that's when
this photographer published a glossy
collector's book on angels which
featured some of the nude photo women
were not compensated right in this dude
which is personal collection of nudes
yes and he's selling it for between 1800
and 3600 two versions of the book Wow
cuz you know my pornhub these are angels
you know why do you know why they
canceled the [ __ ] show the Victoria
Secret Fashion Show
[ __ ] pornhub bro everyone's like oh I
think I could see the house on earth
[ __ ] it for free we're free yeah but no
audio women I'm poor just upgrade our
crazy don't say yeah you could find
anything you want yeah the Internet's
crazy there's no way I mean yeah when I
was of a certain age all Victoria
Secrets all you had telling yeah yeah
yet it like no literally I remember
watching the Victoria's Secret runway
show with my parents and then being like
alright guys well I'm gonna go I'm gonna
take a shower now shower a shower a lot
back in the day was like you know when
you're living with your parents all you
can do so I could do well it just wait
for them to go grocery shopping and [ __ ]
did you hear your dad said he's gonna go
to your shower - no no okay but that's
like yeah I'll see you in there now that
I came I came out of a bathroom and my
parents are like a long shower
my mom did this [ __ ] with me like why
are you taking long showers all of a
sudden and I'm like I'm like oh like
that you know my skin's not so great did
she buy a lecture like that now my
parents knew I was jacking off and they
made jokes about it yeah oh my parents
were like sexual [ __ ] is wrong bumped up
like that kind of my mom just told me
Jesus don't like her when you jack off
too much yeah we're all but once in a
while is okay how much can you do so I
can ask did you just find out you could
just just don't like did Jesus say you
could jerk off four times
[Laughter]
[Music]